hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video ist schon
alleine diese website erkennt ein wahres
alter form finden wir uns heute auf eine
website die ich erwarte ein alter
erkennen das war kein deutsch ob diese
woche steht beantworten die 15 fragen
wir erwarten view bild ja mal schauen ob
die gäste das hinkriegt zunächst einmal
soll mich ein haustier auswählen wieder
einen fisch ein kaninchen einen hund
oder eine katze ich würde sagen ich
nehme einen hund katzen sind
isst du gerne aus wenn ich jetzt lieber
zu hause oder klar ich bin eigentlich
jemand der wäre gern auswärts ist weil
man dann auswärts ist wie entspannt du
am liebsten lesen fernsehgucken oder
schlafen schlafen
ich bin schon guter schläfer wähle deine
lieblings eis worte aus schokolade oder
vanille ich hatte schokoladeneis ich
weiß nicht wie die schokolade
ich finde schokoladen eis schmeckt so
wie ja so irgendwie keine schokolade
irgendwie püriert oder keine ahnung was
weghaut nach vanille keine aussagen von
mir in diesem video bisher haben
jeglichen sinn filme lieber thomas
keller interstellar film also schaue ich
filme lieber zu hause oder im kino ich
würde sagen im kino weil zu hause hat
man halt gar nicht übel feeling das
nicht verstanden heute von mir gesagt
haben ich hab kein bock auf kino das ist
halt nur wieder irgendwie weg euro ich
gucke mir lieber irgendwo auf einer
illegalen website im internet an
beispielen nicht sogar im kino hat man
einen vettel ein wann und vor allem
unterstützt man halt auch die
filmemacher also definitiv im kino süß
oder salzig definitiv weiß ich bisher
können kann ich wirklich alles genau
beantworten ich will das nicht wieder
der lange rede halten und euch sagen
warum ich weiß ich nehme aber ich hätte
einfach wirklich nie schokolade
ich bitte darum keine schokoladen
liebhaber würdest du lieber früh
aufstehen und einen mittagsschlaf halten
oder spät aufstehen und wach bleiben
definitiv spät aufstehen
ich wäre ein später alles klar weder
einen superhelden das ist für mich jetzt
ein bisschen schwierig weil ich
irgendwie nie wirklich super helden
gefeiert habe aber ich würde sagen von
ihnen viel für die spider man eben wie
die karte oder bargeld ich eigentlich
die bargeld mit also dementsprechend
kreditkarte friends oder how i met your
mother wo bestimmt das wie alt ich
angeblich bei oma frieda kein vom ball
trennen derzeit bin ich wieder sehr
krachen
einer sucht asyl für diese anwaltsserie
auf netflix aber wenn ich mich
inzwischen habe der markt entscheiden
würde würde ich die frau mit der
markanten zu dieses bild okay das wird
wahrscheinlich zu infizieren
von wegen hey das war früher die wird
tv-signale störung das können nur leute
die irgendwie vor 2000 geboren sind oder
so wahr ich hatte das selber früher uns
im fernwerk ich kenn das bild aber ich
glaube wenn ich jetzt sage ja ich kenne
nach bildern steckt nämlich definitiv
über 40 jahre älter also ja ich kenne
dieses bild nächste frage kennt diese
bonbon ja ich bin ich auch diese
karamellbonbons mit ihm verstehe warum
man jetzt meine frage an sie unten
einfach dieser mann bekannt er ist
moderator lass mich in ruhe was das ist
genauso beschissen wie diese feste dich
quizmoderator lass mich in ruhe ist ein
schauspieler oder sänger als glaube der
ist ein moderator von rtl oder so
ketchup oder mayonnaise ganz klar kehrt
zum ich hasse mayonnaise und fühle mich
immer richtig fetter nahmen die
mayonnaise etwas dem etikett und die
nächste frage und offen die letzte frage
glaube zum schluss wie wirst du dich
selbst beschreiben als jung oder alt als
ich weiß nicht ich bin jetzt 21
natürlich eigentlich noch relativ junge
im vergleichenden zuschauer
wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen älter
ich würde aber eher sagen junge
anklicken jetzt mal raus und schauen uns
war die auswertung an ihr steht jetzt
calculate meine damen und herren sie war
jetzt ein
diese website sagt dass ich 18 bin ich
habe gedacht ich werde auch künftig
geschätzt oder so genau wie jeder
teenager auf bist du voller energie
neugierig und sorglos nah sind wir nah
dran liegen wir richtig oder falsch sagt
und in den kommentaren
das werde ich dies nicht tun das soll
sich allerdings auch vom video meine
damen und herren ich habe euch den häfen
vermuten in der beschreibung verlinkt da
könnt ihr das selber mal machen tut mir
leid das heutige video nicht allzu lange
war allerdings habe ich in einer
viertelstunde einen termin
weil ich habe mein buch weil sie
arbeiten werde ich weiß nicht was
rauskommt kühl sonst würde ich sagen
meine damen und herren alles vorhaben da
auch das wetter der video nicht am ende
die ausflug adaptierung wie oder konntet
ihr vom video ihr könnt jetzt hier
meinen kanal abonnieren oder hier unten
meinen stecken jetzt bin ich jetzt bei
anderen videos und wellen und könnt ihr
auch die glocken läuten dann bekommt die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]